chaos confusion and mass cancellations
thousands of people living their worst
travel nightmares across the country
just this weekend southwest airlines
cancelling nearly 2 000 flights and the
disruptions continuing today with more
than 350 being called off and another
750 delayed frustration boiling over for
passengers who say they were completely
blindsided we didn't find out until five
o'clock this morning that it was
canceled and then we were on the phone
for what seven hours
44 minutes before they answered the
phone because it was so backlogged they
said
they were having problems
they wouldn't say what it was and you're
lucky you've got a flight the weather's
fine in all connecting areas there's no
there's no bad weather
there's got to be something behind the
scenes that they're not telling us
southwest blaming the problems on air
traffic control issues and severe
weather but the faa contradicting that
claim and says it is not to blame for
what happened now the mass
constellations come during a controversy
over the airline's new vaccine policy
southwest and its pilots union denying
that it had anything to do with a wave
of cancellations but one pilot did warn
it could lead to shortages
it's going to bring the airline industry
to its knees they can't operate with a
10 loss of their work groups currently
this affects the consumer you know we
don't just fly people we fly organs we
fly blood for hospitals medical
equipment fresh food this is going to
affect your economy it's going to affect
your lifestyle and it's going to affect
the markets it is a big deal greg it
seems like the airlines forget that it's
not the 1980s when you if they if they
said there's a weather issue you were
just like oh okay yeah because there was
no way to tell now everybody has it all
on their phone right and also i mean
what you're seeing is the government
didn't do this the government isn't
controlling this this is pilots if this
is true like if it's actually about the
mandates then you're seeing a group of
people who decide that it's imp it's
important enough that they
they can actually control a resource
that can can put a stop to anything
because they believe that they have the
right to i know
the personal is always political for the
left and decades ago that was essential
with jim crow makes the personal
political but now everything personal is
political except i'm willing to bet that
99 of the people that are involved in
this uh stance
it's not us versus them it's not a
political thing i think this is a
personal thing i think it's about their
families and and decisions that they
want to make about their bodies but when
the left introduces politics into an
issue it becomes the prison of two ideas
oh okay you're either ford or you're
against it you're a democrat you're a
republican
but i think that leaves out crowds out
all the reasons and the stories and the
realities that people are uh basing
their decisions on and i think that's
what these pilots are doing i also think
that
we're at this stage where we we keep
redefining
normal everyday stuff you look at
australia right now this accelerated
government intervention in the name of
acceptable risk they keep making risk
and risk less acceptable so you so
government shows up at your house
because you went to an anti-vax mandate
protest and we keep telling people
different things oh this is only for two
weeks oh there's not gonna be a mandate
uh masks don't have to be worn outside
but then every day we slightly change it
so if something becomes more acceptable
and the population falls more and more
in line and it makes you wonder the big
question is what are we going to be like
in 2022 or 2023 like how much will we
accept
right and what could we even be like in
two months jesse that loves the left's
war on christmas could continue with
delays and shortages of pilots right
around the holidays yeah mayor pete's
going to have his hands full i mean he
is really in charge of that where is
mayor pete if you have all this labor
action happening right before the
holidays christmas this is jesse
junior's first christmas he must have
strong feelings jesse jr does have
strong feelings and he said this morning
when i was giving him a walk in the
stroller he said dad joe biden wants
this joe biden was just bragging about
companies laying off the unvac so this
is exactly what happens when you slap a
mandate on like this but dana if you've
read
the latest
in the federalist oh okay sure you have
i like how you wrote the vax mandates a
mirage the rule has never even been
written right it might not even ever be
written and then once it's written it
has to go through lawyers and then once
it's established it's six months until
the companies have to do anything so the
companies fell in line over a press
release over a threat and now you're
seeing the results of that threat i was
in california over the weekend giving a
speech and i ran in into the lobby of
one of these uh i i think she was a
flight attendant could have been a pilot
she works for southwest
she could have been a pilot i didn't she
had a uniform on it was hard to see it
was late at night dana and at first she
was mad at me she said you always trash
southwest and i said there's a lot of
fights there i mean i'm just doing my
job but then she said jesse i have been
at this company for 23 years and they
are about to fire me because i have the
antibodies but because of my religious
reasons i do not want to get the shot
and i am about to be fired after 23
years she said a lot of the other people
a lot of the other people at the other
airlines they're giving religious
exemptions american airlines oh
religious exemption check because they
want to keep people there but southwest
is not doing that they're being real
real tough with it and she actually
predicted that there was going to be
action taken
to have something like this happen and
then the very next day monday look what
happened in august president biden
herald he said the supply chain concerns
really
temporary and that his experts had told
him that uh they would alleviate as the
economy improved but we're not seeing
that and actually the supply chain issue
now it's front page news and every uh
leading we're all leading with it
there's
shelves are empty and now you have the
airline thing and the cascading effect
of that could be that the economy
actually does not improve
without question the the you saw on the
front page of the papers today that some
of the the big retailers
are contracting their own
cargo shippers to bring in product to
make sure that their products on the
shelves and thanksgiving and christmas
look i i think
this airline they mismanaged this thing
without question and whether it's a
mandate or not they should have told
consumers and flyers that they were
going to be in convenience the next day
that being said
the
if i were a passenger on southwest
airlines and i was on a plane with an
unvaccinated pilot with my unvaccinated
seven and six-year-old i'd want to know
and i'm not sure they're sharing it i
think the airline is probably looking at
the liability here and saying that maybe
if we don't have everyone vaccinated
we're going to have an even bigger set
of problems two as i've shared before i
thought colin kaepernick it was right
for teams to be able to say you gotta
stand
when the national anthem is saying all
the people who are defending this
freedom platform for those who wish not
to get vaccinated i applaud you but
let's be consistent uh there's a
consequence if you don't get vaccinated
in the private sector this isn't the
government telling united airlines or
southwest this is that airline saying we
want our pilots and those who work for
us vaccinated that we can disagree with
them i think everyone has the right to
express their freedom however they
choose to but their consequences when
you do express your freedom and indeed
they're living through this if you'd
told me in 2020 last year remember we
were in a presidential race last year we
just had our first debate
against by but biden and president trump
then vice president biden if you told me
that a year later we would have three
vaccines that only 60 percent of
americans would be fully vaccinated less
than 60 percent i would have taken the
bet on the opposite side of that and
probably bet a whole lot at a loss
because i would have thought we would
have three quarters of our nation
vaccinated the first that came on this
show you all were kind to have me on the
show jesse said very clearly if everyone
who's vaccinated still has to wear a
mask that's wrong i'm vaccinated i'm not
the likelihood of me getting this virus
is so is so small and unlikely to be
getting sick from it is very small and
fantastically small those numbers still
exist today i hope people get vaccinated
and those who wish not who choose not to
there will be consequences and obviously
those southwest airline pilots and the
personnel there are experiencing some of
those consequences can i just i'm sorry
can i just
you said something that i think is at
the kernel of this problem it's a the
question of liability is different than
the risk the risk is so small so you're
talking about the liability but you're
talking about a pilot that is not going
to have any contact with the
six-year-old or the five-year-old and
and the air circulation in an airplane
is amazing but greg if you i hear you
but if the pilot is communicating and
has interaction with the flight crew and
the flight crew is delivering apple
juice to my six-year-old or
seven-year-old or or gingerreal that is
contact now look i don't i'm not a
doctor i'm not a professional one thing
i do know i don't care what the
professionals say i do not want to be in
an enclosed environment with someone
who's not who's not vaccinated certainly
did you fly before the vaccine
because i did not spread the spread of
covid was not a problem on planes in
particular period yeah well i don't want
to be the first and everybody so a lot
of this is the fear of the unvaccinated
by the vaccinated and that defies the
logic of getting vaccinated in the first
place let me finish
okay
the
last year we asked
airline
employees to get back on the job
the pilots and the flight attendants and
the gate agents and the baggage handlers
come back to work get america back and
moving well before there was a vaccine
and the spread of covet on airplanes
fully masked and they do enforce those
mask mandates on airlines and even in
the airports the ventilation systems on
these planes so to ask all of these
individuals to work when it was a it was
certainly a lot riskier to do that last
year and then to tell them
take
get a vaccine or you're fired
that is profoundly unfair number one and
number two you're a democrat don't you
believe in the sanctity of the the union
employer contract because that's what
this is about the pilots on friday and
of course this looks like a coinky donk
that the
25
of the flies were cancelled or grounded
yesterday and there was a lawsuit that
was filed on friday by the pilots union
but they're challenging this vaccine
mandate in courts because they say it
violates the railway act so that that's
the root of it but before
i didn't mean to cut you no by no means
before we go if i hear one more person
say pack your patience if you're flying
southwest airlines
i think they should be
pelted with still donuts in public
or throw them out of the uh the
emergency exit well the other thing is
if they tell you that it's weather
related then they don't have to pay for
your hotel
ah
that's what it is i don't know i mean
they say that it's not about the
vaccines i don't know but does that work
with outside of airlines i don't think
so but
this is a credibility problem they blame
the air traffic control and that was
nice
like no they're like whether people are
ultimately ultimately the courts will
decide this well they better hurry up
all right coming up with his agenda on
the ropes president biden is now begging
democrats to unite and give him a
lifeline